one thing i do want to talk about maylin
is uh the viewers don't know this but
you are like
you are like one of the most prolific
google reviewers in japan oh yeah you
are right it used to be
three or four years you thrown you i
just started were you like what's the
highest rank of food reviews
like not high mastery it's like
was it contributor or something like top
five percent or something wow and it
goes it gives you a different score
every month so i didn't even know you
had scores i didn't know right yeah do
they pay you
no did you just do it for like the
clowns
no no she she does it for the prestige i
do for the badges
like it just says oh you're a nervous
certain novice she literally does for
the xbox jeep
so you literally played pokemon go just
in real life yeah
with like restaurants and stuff yeah
yeah yeah yeah to be fair whenever
mainlanders recommend me a restaurant
it's normally very it's usually pretty
good yeah if i've eaten there oh yeah
i'll go there and i'll feel like wow
this is amazing i mean it was like yeah
i'll give it a three out of five and i'm
like what
yeah every time we go to we can't go to
a restaurant with maelyn anymore and
have her enjoy her meal because every
time we're there i can see the cogs
turning you just don't ask me just don't
look at me while i'm eating instead i
can't help it it's like yeah it's super
fascinating watching your thought
process as you as you eat this food i
really enjoy food but i do just eat it
very fast
you do like you're someone who eats food
so fast that i don't know how you can
enjoy it i okay so i've i've
what are your week do you have weekday
eating mode in weekend eating mode
uh
but also when i think when i think when
i think i'm eating this too fast and
then i slow down like my chewing or
whatever i'm like it doesn't really
taste any better
it just makes it more full
does it yeah the slower you eat the
slower you eat the more food you get
yeah
it's like because because it's because
it takes a certain amount of time for
your stomach to process it and for a
signal to get sent to your brain that
says hi i'm full so if you actually eat
slower then it's just a much more
natural way to eat less because then
it'll get full much faster i think if
i'm not like dining with people i don't
really like to take it slow mm-hmm i
like to just eat it and get on with what
i'm doing yeah if you're at like a fancy
restaurant
yeah i'll be like oh my god
you have to try these bananas they're
dashing slowly this swaps
i mean i feel like that's part of the
experience like i think i think part of
the experience of enjoying food with me
is not just the food it's like like
social aspect it's the social aspect and
also the drink as well like having
getting a pair getting the food pad with
like the perfect drink actually like
really enhances the experience
right i feel like i feel like just food
tastes so much worse when you're eating
it alone
do you think so i actually agree yeah
like i like like i don't think so we're
just talking
if it's like abc when i have good food i
feel so sad when no one else is around
to appreciate the good food as well i'm
like this is good you take a picture and
you i mean that's why whatever that's
whenever we got to eat i'm like mailing
it's good right and the maine's like no
but i'm like i'm loving it i'm like this
is great sometimes i'm just like i'm not
gonna ask melin because i am really
enjoying the meal right now and i'm
afraid that she's just gonna dash my
dreams yeah
i don't care people dislike my favorite
shows but when i go to like when we were
at the old studio yeah yeah we had like
the stone bay pizza place yeah that was
really good yeah we loved it and it was
like it was like five 4.5 or something
it was really hard that was fantastic on
google reviews and we took melina miller
was like no
i caught him no it's just because i
don't like pizza to begin with
what what what
what what do you mean you're from like
america wait wait i just got the i just
contender for the shittiest take of the
year that's pretty bad that's pretty bad
why wait wait there's no type of pizza
you like
there is a specific pizza one
that's made in san francisco oh my gosh
oh yes
and the entire
grows
home world
but even though i could only eat like
one pizza a year i don't i don't really
like water
yeah i've
needs to be in san francisco i have
never felt all the italians just [ __ ]
died yeah
italian
there's better foods to eat than pizza i
think
i just think i just thought
every human on earth enjoyed pizza i
just thought it was a mutual love yeah i
just thought it was there it was just
like i'm pretty sure it's like a test
for like how to determine if you're an
alien or a human right because
because like if they don't love pizza
then they're probably an alien right
because no human doesn't love pizza what
do you like about pizza
do you like cheese i think it depends
it's all about timing for pizza when
they get it out and how long they're
cooking if it's crispy soggy
so many places get it wrong
you know
how would you write how would you write
dominoes
i wouldn't rate it like it's like it's
like not even worth it's like not worth
eating okay there's sometimes there's
some moments where you're watching a
movie or something during a long break
and you want to eat something greasy
then pizza the dominoes i'll eat
dominoes right
not like amazing oh okay what is like
the best fast food then in your opinion
if you say in and out i swear to god i
like in and out though i really like it
but yeah but knowing knowing how much
she loves san francisco she's never had
i actually really like mcdonald's yeah
me too me too but like american
mcdonald's japanese mcdonald's japanese
makeup it's all the same no it's not no
american mcdonald's makes me sad
american hamburgers
i would no
american mcdonald's
i just get the nugs nugs are like
universally just the same everywhere
actually fried yeah yeah yeah i mean
nugs nugs are great the fries are great
i think mcdonald's fries are the best i
don't like the major chains but if
they're like soggy it's like well that's
actually they're good when they're soggy
and cold and they've kind of been like
sweating a bit why is this what is this
come on you're joking
what's this
google food reviewer
this is the house this is the
expert when you go on google how to lose
your credibility in like five minutes
like this the google review thing it
doesn't really mean much it just means i
contribute a lot how did that start i'm
so curious about how you just who how
are you literally the only person i know
who does this i think it was an
obsession because like there would be
new restaurants that pop up and then i'd
be the first one
out of everyone in the neighborhood i
mean that is true tokyo like switches
out restaurants like crazy yeah yeah
like restaurants pop up and go yeah yeah
it was really cool whenever i log into
my google maps account and be like wow
you've got a million point 1.2 million
views on your photo i'm like whoa
oh yeah how it feels to be a youtuber
nobody comments they just look at it
which i like like okay they saw
kfc one time and uploaded a picture of
my friend eating a kfc yeah and for some
reason google made the front picture
it was like you click on this kfc it's a
pretty popular kfc and it was just him
sitting there eating a kfc not not a
flattering photo why didn't you upload
that because i wanted to see how it
works that's hilarious i wanted to see
how it worked and i found out afterwards
you can't take down google photos no you
can't and he was furious at me he was
like why did you put it you can take
down google photos really yeah it
wouldn't let me participate maybe it's
the privilege
you're going to be a google reviewer are
you in the top five you know every week
i go on google maps and it's like your
picture is popular
and i'm like what the [ __ ] it's my name
but uh yeah sorry so i mean
so you start reviewing things yeah yeah
when did you get addicted was it like
immediately or like
like after two months i started eating
at more places so do you like go out on
purpose to look for new places or do you
kind of just like wait till a new place
pops up
well i get tired of
eating the same food a lot yeah so
when my husband asks me what do you want
to eat i'll be like can we go somewhere
new i just want like
that stimulation that like excitement i
hate it because i never used to be like
that and then i moved to japan and then
i'm just like i want to eat something
different every day so many japan has
the most for example michelin
restaurants in the world and you don't
even have to eat at a michelin-starred
restaurant everything
if you're a peasant
do you rate the michelin star
restaurants because i know you've been
to it i do i do you do yeah okay but
it's also kind of weird if you go there
often and then the chef knows you rated
them so
i don't they probably they probably
think you're one of like one of the
reviewers at this point one restaurant
that i i really liked yeah and then i
just don't review it because i don't
want them to know my thoughts
what makes a good and a bad reviewer
uh a bad viewer is just like oh this
place was this place sucked or it's too
expensive because i normally only give
out five stars and i don't review
restaurants i don't like
uh yeah that's the problem i think a lot
of people only review restaurants they
hate or some restaurants they really
like yeah right they can't be bothered
to formulate a middle ground yeah when i
look at a place and then i see maybe
there's only three ratings and then i
look at the three reviewers and this
person only has two reviews this person
has 40. i look at their profile so you
don't look at just the reviews you stalk
the account of the reviewer to to
you're like a you're like a jury
analyzer like because
with the credibility of the jurors yeah
because for example if these two
reviewers have a streak or record of
just giving two stars why would i trust
them
i just don't think i have the effort to
like click on something because you
don't care you just uber each everything
but also you don't even check a
restaurant before you try it the people
who normally sound like the biggest
dicks other like the local experts yeah
yeah they always have like the most
snobbish reviews
and like i i every time i read them i'm
like what the [ __ ] happened like he made
it seem like often you read google
reviews uh if i ever go to a new place i
always look at them
really unless i just look at the stars
and i'm like yeah that looks good enough
is that melin's influence no i just
always did that
because sometimes people maybe like
comment like the best dish
yeah pictures of because you don't know
what to order either i don't you know
sometimes i don't really know and
occasionally i can't read it cause it's
all in kanji and then i'm like i pointed
the picture i'm like give me this one
yeah what the [ __ ] it's like a menu what
this guy had
you don't do that no that's a weirdo
menus here that have no pictures and
yeah
yeah sometimes go through the picture
sometimes you just gotta put your face
also yeah i do gods and just order food
i don't know
just throw the dice what do you do in
that situation it's awesome ask for the
recommendation yeah what aubry says
you're like yes
i hope this is good i just get whatever
sounds nice i don't know like sometimes
sometimes you hungry joe's that [ __ ] but
joey can read yeah
i'm dumb there's some like handwritten
menus i'm just like one oh yeah
those are so hard to even like remotely
figure out what's being like said and oh
if that's the case then i asked the
waitress i'm like what does that say
i actually have if
sometimes like i've seen some
handwritten ones especially like really
fancy like japanese restaurants where
they're like love to use that like
traditional calligraphy style and i'm
like yeah like this just looks like
squiggles to me that one's with the hugo
audi
i mean like daily specials will always
ask but like i've seen menus that is
literally illegible where it's just so
messy and they always use like fancy
terminology that you just doesn't work
outside of that context
my favorite moment of eating in japan is
when you go to ryokan it's like 20
courses
and they just come over to you and
explain every dish and i just look at
the thing for like two minutes straight
just nodding
i'm actually interested in those kinds
of menus though i don't know what
they're saying to me oh i'm just like
what the [ __ ] you say yeah i'm like
nodding nodding all right this is
getting a little like in your head it's
like this is food this is also food this
is a food
called
i think you eat it or take like half a
bite and then tell them what is this
that i just say and then they that
that's better like if they have time but
like usually what they do is they bring
all the food out right and then they
explain it and then they just [ __ ] off
yeah you don't even have enough time
unless you're eating it as they're
explaining it all right
i'm just like come back please i need to
come over here i want to i am
formulating a review i took a picture
and i have to leave notes next
are you the local expert do you get that
badge as well
well i'm not sure
hey like i'm just so curious like how
often do you have to eat at somewhere
new to be in the top five percent i have
no idea i haven't been top five percent
since like
2017 that's worrying because you do
quite a lot of reviews yeah how many
reviews does it take to be in the top i
have no idea becoming more mainstream